gvt est effectivement vous raconter une
histoire une histoire d'équipé et une
histoire en pet qui me tient à coeur
particulièrement parce qu'elle est belle
dans tout ce qu'elle peut prévoir pour
permettre aux jeunes de s'exprimer
on a depuis en fait un certain temps
dans la vision de l'enseignement
beaucoup en fait deux choses à vouloir
dire à vouloir exprimer
mais pas toujours les bonnes les bons
créneaux pour pouvoir en fait le faire
nous avons eu la chance en fait d'avoir
une ministre de l'environnement qui a
voulu être à l'écouté des étudiants de
suisse
et nous avons reçu un jour en mars 2014
signé de la ministre l'environnement et
du territoire
une missive qui nous disait très
simplement je souhaite que vous
participiez à un concours ce concours
s'est imaginé la suisse son territoire
en 2035
alors lorsqu'on reçoit en fait une telle
missive
évidemment que c'est pas anodin c'est
pas tous les jours qu'on reçoit une
lettre de d'un ministre ou d'une
ministre et je vous promets en fait que
cette histoire a été relativement courte
belle mais qu'elle a plein
d'applications en fait sur nous et c'est
ce ce que je veux vous raconter ce soir
dans la vision en fait de ça surtout
vous dire que non seulement on a
participé mais qu'on a réussi à être
lauréat du goncourt
et tout ceci en fait entre ces deux
moments le moment où nous recevons une
missive et le mans où on réussit
finalement à donner des avis à montrer
que les étudiants ont une vision sur
l'avenir leur vision pas celle qu'on a
voulu reposer et bien il y a un grand
pas à faire et se passait justement le
travail dans une équipe et avec en fait
plein d'étudiants pleinement en plein de
jeunes et ces jeunes en fait ça va
beaucoup mieux réfléchir qu'on ne le
pense il faut simplement leur donner la
parole au bon moment mais ça n'est pas
toujours si facile de leur donner
la parole au bon moment pourquoi parce
que la lettre en fait en question elle
disait juste demain la suisse son
territoire mais avec aucune précision on
a voulu en savoir voulait sous quelle
forme
le rendu en fait qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez avoir y avait aucune
obligation sous quelle forme
comment quoi imaginer vous êtes
totalement libre
et lorsqu'on est totalement libre vous
savez qu'on perd un tout petit peu en
fait le nord par contre c'est l'occasion
ou jamais et en ce qui me concerne je
suis biologiste de formation ingénieur
en environnement
j'avais depuis longtemps imaginé que ce
pouvait être possible dans une école de
travailler un petit peu différemment
par contre dans mon parcours lorsque
j'ai quitté mon bureau après 27 ans j'ai
été attiré dans cette école par l'idée
de réunir deux écoles d'en faire une
école basée sur la durabilité sur
l'interdisciplinarité et sur la vision
en fait demain tous les ingénieurs
travaillent ensemble et c'est des
opportunités comme celles là qui donne
tout à coup l'idée en fait de pouvoir
effectivement concrétisé quelques idées
et il faut pouvoir saisir ce moment
c'est une des grandes particularités que
l'on peut avoir dans une école nous
n'avons pas vraiment d'obligations autre
que celle d'enseigner de faire de la
recherche
mais avec beaucoup de liberté mais
encore faut-il avoir l'occasion de les
prendre
ces libertés est alors forcément avec
plein d' enthousiasme
j'ai envoyé la lettre et j'ai invité
tous les partenaires des différentes
filières en lin neuf dans l'école a
participé à cet événement et c'est le
premier point de chute
totalement aux fêtes difficile à vivre
c'est à dire en gros la réponse pas le
temps c'est à dire qu'en fait en mars
pour prévoir en fait un rendu en
septembre organisé le tout avec des
étudiants si possible alors que les
grandes vacances vous le savez commence
à peu près à mi juin dans les autres
écoles on se retrouve effectivement avec
des gens qui vous répondent j'ai pas le
temps
j'ai pas la possibilité en fait de
finalement organiser quelque chose et je
me retrouve avec un gros problème sur le
brun
à partir de là c'est la première chose
que j'ai dû à faire et peut-être la
seule j'ai dû tuer la créativité c'est à
dire en fait que ce que je voulais
évidemment s'était amené à imaginer à
créer quelque chose une idée et partir
de là la première chose que j'ai dû
faire c'est donner un ordre de marche et
en disant en fait ce n'est pas un choix
c'est une obligation de répondre à notre
ministre ça commence mal évidemment
partir de là en fait on se retrouve en
situation de d'imaginer que nous devons
obliger un petit peu les gens à devoir
être créatif
par contre lorsqu'on leur explique
vraiment les enjeux des enjeux de
visibilité les enjeux généraux en fait
de pouvoir enfin utiliser une liberté
pour s'exprimer et oser dire que l'on
existe qu'on n'est pas dans une boîte
c'est effectivement quelque chose
d'important
alors on a commencé effectivement réunir
tout le monde est à partir de cette
vision de dire on est totalement libre
on a quand même pris le temps de se dire
dans quel sens on réduit notre liberté
c'était une grande liberté pouvoir le
faire tout seul et dans ce sens là nous
avons fait commencé à imaginer à dire et
bien évidemment on va essayer de
travailler sur une évolution du
développement durable on va essayer de
travailler avec la vision de
l'innovation mais tout de suite on s'est
posé la question c'est quoi l'innovation
et nous avons eu alors très rapidement
aussi un consensus et je pense que là
c'est pas pour rien qu'on est dans une
même école innovation d'après en fait
mes collègues économistes
c'est toujours en fait lié à une valeur
ajoutée valeur ajoutée économique
généralement une production et nous
avons pris quelques exemples pour bien
nous montrer que ce que ces économistes
ou disait n'était pas la panacée et
qu'on pouvait aller en fait beaucoup
plus loin vous connaissez tous
ce genre d'innovation en plus de ça
c'est le must
les cleantech aujourd'hui lorsqu'on
n'est pas clean et qu'on n'est pas
technologique
on n'est rien comment de l'industrie et
bien c'est cleantech vous fabrique des
belles choses comme celles là vous avez
tous certainement eu une fois la
tentation ou déjà utilisé ce genre de
petits lots pas l'air pour vos jardins
c'est effectivement une technologie dans
lequel on peut dire je mets de la
lumière
c'est le soleil en fait qui me leur
charge le jour la nuit en fait je ne
consomme rien et en fait pourquoi alors
aux boules de cinq ans sap a duré plus
que cinq ans pour retrouver tous ces
petits lampadaires avec le plastique le
faire et l'ensemble du silicium qui
forme les petites en fait panneaux
solaires voulais retrouver à la
déchetterie tout simplement parce que
vous en avez marre de voir les
différentes étoiles dans votre jardin
vous préférez les voir là haut vous avez
marre de voir la lumière partout alors
que vous préférez rentrée de temps en
temps aussi
on apprécie en fait la nuit et surtout
il y à la pérennité en fait de ces
engins et c'est typiquement quelque
chose ou on n'a pas du tout imaginé que
cette technologie dite clean pouvait
avoir des impacts environnementaux et
pourtant c'est important donc on l'a dit
en tout cas on veut pas ça la deuxième
chose en fait qu'on a dit aussi c'est on
ne veut pas du faux c'est à dire vous
imaginez une belle villa est aujourd'hui
les architectes puisque on forme aussi
des architectes sont évidemment tous
branchés sur la villa de demain ans la
ville a aussi en fait dit minergie ou
voir même minergie plus ou simplement
auto suffisante voire même productrice
à partir de là on se retrouve alors la
plupart du temps aujourd'hui ces belles
villas dit minergie qui sont construites
à pétaouchnok quelque part en fait très
très loin où on habite
parce que ça coûte un peu plus cher et
donc on va chercher le terrain le plus
loin possible pour être moins chers pour
compenser en fait le prix la maison
minergie
résultat des courses vous retrouver dans
un coin où l'hiver il faut pour se
déplacer donc il faut changer la voiture
ou 4 4 deuxièmement il n'y a pas en fait
du tout encore de transport en commun
donc les enfants faisaient apportez donc
faut une deuxième voiture et vous
retrouvez avec une maison minergie
mais avec 2 4 4 pour pouvoir en fait ils
vivent dedans on l'a en fait tout de
suite imaginé que c'est pas ça qu'on
voulait alors la question que pose
souvent à l'ingénieur a été pour nous de
dire si on prenait les exemples clé de
ce qu'on nous a déjà posé comme question
à savoir dans le problème immense que la
circulation de ce flux de personnes
entre lausanne et genève entre
le train est entre la voiture de savoir
finalement qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important pour vous ingénieurs est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est mieux en fait
d'avoir une troisième ligne de train ou
une troisième voie de voiture évidemment
vous aurez en fait toutes les personnes
qui vont en fait être les pros et les
antis en fait d'une des deux variantes
et dans tous les cas le résultat est le
même on se retrouve à favoriser le
déplacement donc à engorger l'ensemble
en fait de nos réseaux à partir de là la
discussion remo et commencer à dire mais
une vraie réponse d'ingénieurs télé
niort et de jeunes qui ont cette vision
développement durable et vision en fait
d'une génération différente se
poseraient la question différemment
comment faire pour réduire les
déplacements et là l'imagination était
très vite aussi sur la table
nous allons créer le plus grand club
d'échangistes de romandie et ce club
d'échangistes il va échanger villa
contre 1 5 pièces à genève ville à
lausanne contre un cinq pièces à genève
avec en fait vue sur le lac ou non mais
avec des possibilités effectivement de
pouvoir se dire je vais gagner en plus
de ça deux jours dans ma vie 1 2 jours 2
heures dans ma vie tous les jours et
permettra si a échangé pendant deux ans
trois ans ou à l'internât mme un
ensemble effectivement de biens de
valeur et pourquoi pas en fait créer
quelque chose qui permette à fait aller
de l'avant évidemment comme dans tous
les clubs échangistes et dans toutes les
offres qu'en fait on peut aller bien
plus loin est en fait bien plus si
entente c'était en fait la vision que
nous avons voulu donner mais aller plus
loin veut dire aussi que pourquoi ne pas
échanger un banquier de lausanne contre
un banquier de genève qui habite en fait
lui à lausanne est lui à genève
donc aussi en fait une bourse à l'emploi
à échanger finalement que les banquiers
essayant de mettre des faux comptes
à défaut non par rapport en fait à sa à
genève ou à lausanne qu'il le fasse en
fait dans l'eau ou dans l'autre servent
exactement au même
donc on s'est dit effectivement qu'on
pouvait aller beaucoup plus loin et
trouver des solutions où il faut éviter
ça nous avons commencé le vrai travail
de brainstorming
mais pour ça en fait on a inculqué une
notion très simple c'est qu'il fallait
en fait penser différemment penser
différemment en disant si vous prenez
cet adage qui est à mon avis très bon
lorsque vous avez comme seul outil un
marteau tout ressemble à des clous parce
que vous le devez l'utiliser donc
effectivement il n'ya pas effectivement
grand chose à dire et la deuxième chose
c'est aussi de dire que généralement on
l'appelle expérience ce que nous avons
fait tout le long de notre vie mais nous
avons fait peut-être tout faux long de
notre vie et dont nous avons nous
n'arrivons pas à nous débarrasser partir
de là en fait cette mauvaise expérience
il faut donc trouver la manière de
l'éviter l'éviter ça veut dire qu'il
vaut déjà évincé tous les professeurs
les penseurs professionnels payés pour
ça il faut donc en fait écarter la
plupart en fait des gens qui normalement
donne des conseils il faut aussi se
libérer du temps et il faut trouver une
capacité à travailler dans la terre
disciplinaire c'est à dire que des gens
qui n'ont aucune notion d'un domaine
puissent avoir un avis le donnait le
comparer le confronter et donner des
visions en fait totalement peut-être
nouvelle vous savez que l'idée en fait
même de la créativité vient que
lorsqu'on est une question qui nous
traverse la tête il faut pouvoir trouver
la manière d'un justement déborder de
toutes ces questions habituelles et de
toutes les réponses habituelles que nous
avons et à savoir en fait que les
réponses connu l'adaptation des réponses
connu l ensemble des variantes possibles
sur le même thème doivent disparaître
pour qu'enfin on puisse peut-être être
vraiment à plat et commencer à trouver
devoir trouver d'autres chemins pour
arriver à une réponse correcte et bien
ce bout là nous l'avons réussi
parfaitement
nous avons organisé une semaine de
brainstorming de travail avec les
étudiants et les assistants encadrés par
quelques professeurs et à partir de là
au bout du troisième jour donc le
mercredi soir
nous n'avions effectivement fait que la
première partie et nous nous étions
arriviez à ce point d'interrogation
c'est à dire rien n'était sorti et on
était en fait dans une phase complète
c'est là que les miracles arrivent très
longtemps et pendant la nuit les gens
commençaient à fait acquitter leur
domaine énormément domaine j'arrive plus
rien et réfléchir je vais y réfléchir
sur le domaine de l'autre puisqu'on
avait des architectes génère civile des
architectes paysagistes on avait en fait
des gestionnaires la nature et ils ont
chacun pensait dans le domaine de
l'autre et c'est à partir de ce moment
là que la vraie réflexion le jeudi matin
a commencé à se faire ou les agronomes
ont commencé à se soucier de ce qui se
passait dans la ville et vice versa et
la créativité a eu lieu simplement par
confrontation en fait de ses idées à
partir de là cette créativité
elle a donné effectivement n'ont pas
lieu à une innovation que moins de faire
chaque chaque fois mais a une vraie
vision de qu'elle serait ou quel que
soit ton nous comme vision pour notre
futur de la en fait on a eu des échanges
et ces échanges responsable c'est
effectivement de dire nous devons
échanger nos savoir-faire nos
compétences entre nous et dans le
journal qui a séduit le jury en fait de
ce concours lancé par madame la ministre
s'est par exemple en fait le succès
incroyable des prestations sociales
requise les prestations sont en aveux
qu'ils sont venus l'agronomie qui ont
des prestations écologiques requises
on donne des subventions par rapport en
fait à des exigences de base et donc
effectivement la vision de ce que
pourrait être demain un quartier est
bien l'idée c'est que on fasse un projet
de quartier qu'aux enfants projets dans
le territoire où on se met tous d'accord
ensemble et au finalement pour financer
les crèches le soutien familial
l'ensemble la créativité en fait est
jeune on se retrouve à pouvoir
effectivement avancé idem
ils ont imaginé que depuis le temps
qu'on en parle qu'on vous dit maintenant
en fait que la retraite va encore
peut-être est repoussée parce qu'on est
près mds ils ont dit mais attendez il
faut effectivement qu'on arrive à
travailler vraiment à la maison les
imaginer une loi qui oblige chaque
employeur pour
autant qu'ils puissent pas prouvé que
c'était possible donner au moins une
journée de travail à la maison à
l'ensemble des employés de suite et de
là ils en ont découlé tout ce que on
pouvait avoir comme avantage et de
vision sur l'ensemble de cette vision du
futur elles ont repeuplé la périphérie
celle en fait vous avez que des villas
qui sont faites l'une derrière l'autre
ou l'une devant l'autre
ils ont recréé des vrais villages mais
avec une vision en fait vraiment
concrètes qu'elles soient économiques
qu'elles soient sociales ou qu'elles
soient simplement en fait d'une vision
de la volonté de recréer non pas en fait
des déplacements entre un lieu de
travail un autre mais un lieu de vie où
on peut faire le tout à la fois ils ont
imaginé évidemment d'autres choses
c'est par exemple utiliser l'eau de
pluie pour en fait nos wc vous le savez
en fait vous utilisez de l'eau potable
pour évacuer nos vos déchets et on se
retrouve effectivement avec une vision
très claire en fait de ce que l'on
pourrait faire en fait là temps et ceci
en fait sur plusieurs pages d'un grand
document parce qu'ils ont pris le pari
que en 2035 le papier existerait encore
pour les bonnes choses évidemment plus
pour les gratuits
mais pour en fait ce qui compte vraiment
et pour expliquer ce que serait en 2035
elles ont fait en fait une vision d'être
en 2035 et de faire la rétrospective de
this tout ce qui nous a bloqués mais
aussi tout ce qui nous a permis de
débloquer des situations dans cette
vision là alors évidemment c'est quelque
chose où l'innovation en fait n'a pas
été vraiment présente mais je suis
extrêmement content de pouvoir montrer
qu l'innovation sans production de
valeur commerciale est une vraie
innovation et cela commence à créativité
celle des jeunes si vous pensez que ça
n'est pas possible je vous engage tous
en fête à revenir suivre des cours à
l'école ça fait du bien vous verrez et
ma plus grande joie personnelle c'est
qu'une école d'ingénieurs et
d'architectes a produit des solutions
qui ne sont pas techniques mais qui sont
au contraire des visions de société et à
partir de là en fait de croire vraiment
que l'interdisciplinarité la vision que
les jeunes peuvent avoir collectivement
va nous donner
solution viable est extrêmement
intéressante en fait pour demain et pour
conclure de dire que le tout et le
gâteau pour nous la cerise en fait au
gâteau c'est de trouver une suite à tout
ceci
d'abord un projet d'école qui va se
perpétuer chaque année sur la vision de
dire nous devons nous pouvons nous le
donnons la liberté de modifier la vision
qu'ont les politiciens et l'ensemble en
fait d'eux des gens qui pensent toute la
journée qu'ils sont payés pour ça
mais nous voulons un esprit jeune et
nous donnerons la visite de madame
l'oeil tares de notre école parce
qu'effectivement elle a trouvé
intéressant de venir écouter ces jeunes
et encore plus loin que d'avoir
simplement jetés en fait comme ça à la
pâture un programme et un appel à
candidatures et ces services devront
réfléchir sur deux solutions proposées
par nos étudiants pour pouvoir les
mettre en application dans les années à
venir et ça c'est effectivement quelque
chose de très beau et puis repenser en
fait chaque année avec les jeunes
une vision il a donné en fait à tout un
chacun en ce qui me concerne c'est une
excellente vision de ce qui m'a amené à
être une fois directeur d'une école et
de pensée contrairement à ce qui était
dit avant c'est vrai que doivent parfois
oublier ce qu'on a appris mais on peut
aussi apprendre à mieux apprendre dans
les écoles et c'est à ce stade là que je
m'arrête pour vous dire que j'ai espoir
que nos écoles forme de mieux en mieux
les jeunes vous les jeunes le telle
manière à pouvoir nous donner un vrai
futur avec une vraie liberté
merci beaucoup